maintenant tu vas laisser sa place à hip
hop qua non ça va moi je bouge plus
maintenant
oh oui fazila venons de parler du film
et je veux faire une petite interview
première fois ses premières fois c'est
quoi première fois par exemple je veux
dire ton premier souvenir qu'on ait
souvenir c'est un rêve
ouais c'était quoi c'est un loup est un
renard qui ne parlent dans un jardin et
qui viennent me dire que l'herbe pousse
à ce moment là je regarde
non c'est sérieux c'est vrai nous allons
par le vexer et je regarde vers le ciel
et je vois une fenêtre qui s'ouvre
j'essaye de parler à cette fenêtre cette
fenêtre ne répond pas ouais je t'ai pas
dit on premiers pétards jetés c'était
mon premier souvenir de la première
baffe la première baffe en fait la
première dont je me souvienne c'était
dans une île il ya un mec qui m'a chopé
parce que je parlais à ses copines n'ont
pas tout à fait banale et m'a chopé un
nom je me souviendrai rigoriste un
égoïste les gosses c'est pas beau ton
premier objet fétiche tu t'en souviens
non mais en vieux fusil frêche c'est
tout à fait clair la première boum
au fond la colle et le mec dans son coin
comme ça vous arrive et j'ai maintenant
j'ai pas les danses et à la première
bouée tapisserie sa première idole
mairie donne c'est président n est pas
une idole si peut-être un peintre que
j'aimais vous qui s'appelle paul klee
mais c'est vrai c'était pas mike brant
où il a dit un point tri n'a pas d'une
tâche
ton premier amour vrai amour au premier
vrai amour cinéma tu es la tête et j'ai
ramé comme un dingue pour la voir j'ai
vraiment ramé ramé le jour j si c'était
bon que j'ai réussi à faire une combine
avec sa soeur copain à moi un truc
incroyable juste pour la voir elle était
super ça marche on a eu un accident tout
est toujours des visions de la gueule
sous la gueule arracher la crise c'est
mon premier amour mais les deux mais
vachement première expérience sexuelle
ça s'est passé très calmement
non ces gens pareils séjour incluant
incroyable ses côtés jean dernier moment
c'était genre la porte qui s'ouvre dans
le couloir nous et dans la chambre la
porte sous dans le couloir un bruit
genre tu vois ma chérie et au bas mot
qui s'oublie de partir par la fenêtre on
était bel et bien présent sexuelle sa
première cuite
la première cuite massachusetts a
prévenu
premier président richard premier pétard
le premier pétard je me souviens d'une
grande parade la première vraie grande
parade aux direct premier pétard ça
c'est clair
premiers acides premier incident ses
seuls s'est jamais redescendu samak
avait été acceptée à la campagne oui
mais qu'est ce t'as bu qu'est-ce que non
j'ai rien vu j'ai pu je fais ça parce
que tu es vrai j'avais mes doigts comme
ça c'est le coup j'ai vu mes doigts qui
l'a arrêté
c'est vraiment ton premier succès ses
premiers succès ouais c'est quoi un
succès je sais pas moi je m'en tiens à
ce succès tombe silhouette est un succès
que je cours plus tard mais avant je
n'avais vu des petits quoi j'en ferai du
bien
ouais genre bon plaisir ce matin
lâchement du bien pour sagan aussi
d'obama n'ont évidemment magnifique où
c'est la première télé du corps souvient
en tournage tu veux dire où on obtient
comme ça on l'invité on habitait web et
sept gardes tirent bien qu'il invite
pour faire gens sont des missions qu'ils
allaient et mardi cinéma
ouais mardi cinéma c'était au moment où
il y avait des manifs dans la rue
peut-être 80 système d'étudiants et
d'étudiantes et je sais pas j'ai
commencé à me prendre la tête avec un
truc sur astérix
un film qui était fait en fait je me
suis chauffer tout seul j'ai gueulé très
bien que les tirs venaient à 20 10 mai
vous savez parler ici c'est simple je
suis moi pourquoi tu veux pas aller à
sacrée soirée
c'est quoi ça c'est ça tu travailles
comme ça et tu fais des exercices pour
améliorer ton nom mais non pas un acteur
qui a beaucoup travaillé avant justement
donc tu travailles way et je suis obligé
de travailler avant de caler steam way
se déroule parce que je suis pas bon
ouais mais c'est vrai que tu fais des
exercices pour apprendre à rire je fais
des assises pour essayer de pouvoir
peut-être un tout petit peu donné l'idée
que ça pourrait être un rire ouais mais
j'ai un début quoi jeu